is that the source
of uh if you were able to deconstruct
like where some of your best ideas came
from
do is there a process that's at the core
of that
yeah like so some people you know walk
and think some people like in the shower
the best ideas hit him
if you talk about like newton apple
hitting him on the head
no i i found out a long time ago i
process things somewhat slowly
so like in college i had friends that
could study at the last minute get an a
next day
i can't do that at all so i always front
loaded all the work
like i do all the problems early you
know
for finals like the last three days i
wouldn't look at a book
because i want you know because like a
new fact the day before finals may screw
up my understanding of what i thought i
knew
so my my goal was to always get it in
and and give it time to soak and
i used to you know i remember we were
doing like 3d calculus i would have
these amazing dreams of 3d surfaces with
normal
you know calculating the gradient and
this is like all come up
so it was really fun like very visual
and uh and if i got cycles of that that
was useful
um and the other is don't over filter
your ideas
like i like that process of
brainstorming where lots of ideas can
happen i like people who have lots of
ideas
and things but that's where it's upset
then there's a yeah i'll let them sit
and let it breathe
a little bit and then reduce it to
practice
like at some point you really have to
does it really work like you know is
this real or not
right but you but you have to do both
there's creative tension there
like how do you be both open and
you know precise if you had ideas that
you just
that sit in your mind for like years
yeah before the
sure it's an interesting uh way to
just generate ideas and just let them
sit let them sit there for a while
i think i have a few of those ideas you
know that was so funny
yeah i think that's you know creativity
uh this one or something
for the slow thinkers in the in the room
i suppose
as i some people like you said are just
like like
the yeah it's really interesting there's
so much diversity in how people think
you know how fast or slow they are how
well they remember don't
like you know i'm not super good at
remembering facts but processes and
methods
like in our engineering i went to penn
state and almost all our engineering
tests were open book i could remember
the page and not the formula
but as soon as i saw the formula i could
remember the whole method if i'd
if i'd learned it yeah you know so it's
just a funny
or some people could you know i i
swatched friends like flipping through
the book trying to find the formula
even knowing that they'd done just as
much work and i would just open the book
and i was on page 27
about half i could see the whole thing
visually
yeah and you know and you have to learn
that about yourself and figure out what
to do
yeah function optimally i had a friend
who he was always concerned he didn't
know how he came up with ideas
he had lots of ideas but he said they
just sort of popped up
like you'd be working on something you
have this idea like where does it come
from
but you can have more awareness of it
like like
like like how you how your brain works
is a little murky as you go down
from the voice in your head or the
obvious visualizations
like when you visualize something how
does that happen yes
you know if i say you know visualize
volcano it's easy to do right
and what does it actually look like when
you visualize it i can visualize to the
point where i don't see
very much out of my eyes and i see the
colors of the thing i'm visualizing
yeah but there's like there's a shape
there's a texture there's a color but
there's also conceptual visualization
like
what are you actually visualizing when
you're visualizing volcano just like
with peripheral vision you think you see
the whole thing yeah yeah
that's a good way to say it you know you
have this kind of
almost peripheral vision of your
visualizations they're like these ghosts
but if you know if you if you work on it
you can get a pretty high level of
detail
and somehow you can walk along those
visualizations to come up with an idea
which is uh but weird but when you're
thinking about
solving problems like you're putting
information
and you're exercising the stuff you do
know you're sort of teasing the
area that's you don't understand and
don't know
but you can almost you know feel
you know that process happening you know
that's that's how i
like like like i know sometimes when i'm
working really hard on something like
like i get really hot when i'm sleeping
and you know it's like
we got the blank throw i wake up all the
blankets are on the floor
and you know every time it's while i
wake up and think wow that was great
you know are you able to uh to reverse
engineer what the hell happened there
oh sometimes it's vivid dreams and
sometimes it's this kind of like you say
like shadow thinking that you you sort
of have this feeling you're
you're going through this stuff but it's
it's not that obvious isn't that so
amazing that the mind just
does all these little experiments i
never you know i thought i always
thought
it's like a river that you can't you're
just there for the ride but you're right
if you prep it
no it's it's all understandable
meditation really helps
you got to start figuring out you need
to learn language of your own mind
and there's multiple levels of it but
yeah abstractions again right it's
somewhat comprehensible and
observable and feelable or whatever the
right word is
you know it's yeah you're not long for
the ride
you are the ride
you